[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend Rudi Cerne heute wieder mit
jeder Menge Wintersport hallo und
schönen guten Abend die Nachrichtenlage
jetzt im Überblick
massive Angriffswelle auf die Ukraine
mit Flugabwehrwaffen gelingt es
ukrainischen Soldaten viele der
russischen Raketen unschädlich zu machen
Stau bei wohngeldauszahlung viele neue
Antragsteller aber zu wenig Behörden
Mitarbeiter experten befürchten
wochenlange Verzögerungen
und wintersportfest nach zwei Jahren
corona-pause 25.000 Fans begleiten den
Auftakt der Vierschanzentournee in
Oberstdorf
[Musik]
wir schauen zu Beginn der Sendung in die
Ukraine wo es heute großflächigen
Luftalarm gab und gibt dutzende
russische Marschflugkörper wurden
Richtung Ukraine abgefeuert die
Luftschläge mit Drohnen mit Raketen
betraften fast das gesamte Land das
ukrainische Militär spricht von
insgesamt 69 russischen Angriffen
ausgeführt von Schiffen und Flugzeugen
54 feindliche Raketen sein abgeschossen
worden für uns in Kiew ist Anne Brühl
eine russische cruise-messeil im Anflug
auf ein Ziel in der Nähe von Kiew die
Botschaft der Bilder ist klar die
Luftabwehr der Ukraine funktioniert
trotzdem gibt es Zerstörung drei
Menschen werden in einem Vorort von Kia
verletzt als abgeschossene
raketentrümmerhäuser treffen
Tatjana was sie livnas Tochter und ihre
Enkelin werden im Krankenhaus behandelt
sie hatte große Angst sie hat so ins
Telefon geschrieben dass ich nicht
einmal verstehen konnte was hier
passiert ist
rettungskräfte sind vor Ort und
traumatisierte Anwohner die einfach nur
Glück hatten
es gab eine sehr starke Explosion bei
uns wurden Fenster und Türen aufgedrückt
wir wurden an die Wand geschleudert
in Kiew wird es immer schwerer so etwas
wie Normalität aufrecht zu erhalten mehr
als 40% der Menschen sind ohne Strom
sagt uns Bürgermeister Klitschko ist
kein Geheimnis der Russen wollen uns
frieren lassen ohne Heizung ohne
Elektrizität ohne Wasser wie
kontrollieren die ganze Situation aber
trotzdem ist
wir waren schon paar mal sehr nah zum
sogenannte Blackout
suchen in der abwarten bis der Luftalarm
aufgehoben wird für die Menschen in Kiew
gehört das schon lange zum Alltag
es ist schwer jeden Tag Angst zu haben
und das Leben auf später zu vertagen
Leben überleben am Ende dieses ersten
Kriegsjahres
der Bericht von Anne Brühl mit der wir
jetzt sprechen möchten Anne wie hast du
die Angriffe im Raum Kiew erlebt
ja die Angriffe die haben hier heute
morgen so kurz nach 8 Uhr begonnen wir
haben heftige Explosionen gehört hier im
Zentrum von Kiew konnten dann von hier
oben auch sehen wie die ukrainische
Luftabwehr diese russischen Raketen
abschießt insgesamt wurden ja alle 16
Raketen die für Kiew bestimmt waren
abgefangen der Luftalarm hier wurde
danach zweieinhalb Stunden aufgelöst das
war aber für das ganze Land insgesamt
die zehnte große russische Angriffswelle
auf Ziele der Infrastruktur sie war
durchaus auch erfolgreich es gab 15
Treffer
die sind von der Stromversorgung
abgeschnitten die ist unterbrochen und
das ist etwas was viele Ukrainer
befürchtet hatten gerade mit Blick auf
neue Jahr das ist hier das große
Familienfest eines dass sie jetzt zum
ersten Mal im Krieg verbringen müssen
und das macht vielen Menschen hier Sorge
live aus Käfer das andere Brühl vielen
Dank
wir gehen weiter nach Israel nach fünf
Parlamentswahlen in dreieinhalb Jahren
sehen viele die Demokratie dort auf dem
Prüfstand heute wurde die neue Regierung
vom Parlament bestätigt und diese
Regierung ist ultra rechts wie nie
entsprechend groß die Unruhe und auch
die Aufgabe für den aus der Opposition
zurückgekehrten alten und neuen
rekordregierungschef nitaniao aus Tel
Aviv Thomas Reichert
Benjamin netanjahuas zurück an der Macht
und gibt dafür Nationalisten und
ultra-orthodoxen so viel ab davon wie
nie zuvor in Israel Geschichte
schwach schwach ruft deshalb die
Opposition und Netanjahu wehrt sich
sie werden die Vormachtstellung Israels
in der Region sicherstellen indem wir
ständig stärker werden
vor dem Parlament demonstrieren hunderte
Veteranen LGBT und Bürgerrechte
Religion der Luftwaffe in einem offenen
Brief mit über 1.000 anderen Veteranen
waren der Israels Demokratie sei bedroht
die Politik dieser Regierung
widerspricht fast allem woran wir
glauben nämlich der Demokratie den
Liberalismus und den jüdischen Werten
oberste Priorität für die neue Regierung
hatte Siedlungsausbau auch in den
Gebieten die Palästinenser für sich und
ihren künftigen Staat werden
beanspruchen die Siedlungspolitik sollen
als Minister anti-arabische Extremisten
mitbestimmen die Palästinenser
ihrerseits drohen auf Gewalt mit Gewalt
zu antworten
ich glaube dass wir auf eine sehr
schmerzhafte Zeit zu steuern nicht nur
für die Palästinenser sondern ich denke
auch dass dies Auswirkungen auf die
Sicherheit der Israelis haben wird
schon beim Antritt spaltet die neue
Regierung das Land so noch mehr
netanjau kommt für seine Rückkehr als
Ministerpräsident den Extremisten in
seiner Regierung weit entgegen sie
setzen nun eine antiliberale Politik
durch die den auskonflikt anfeuern und
die Demokratie in Israel gefährden
könnte
der
Gesundheitszustand des im irritierten
Papstes Benedikt ist weiterhin ernst
aber nach Angaben des Vatikans im Moment
auch stabil der 95-Jährige sei
vollkommen wach und geistig präsent der
amtierende Papst franziskus hatte
gestern erklärt benedikt der 16 sei sehr
krank
der Konflikt auf dem Westbalkan scheint
vorerst entschärft das Kosovo hat seinen
wichtigsten Grenzübergang zu Serbien
wieder geöffnet zuvor hatte Serbiens
Präsident Vucic dazu aufgerufen die
Straßenblockaden im Grenzgebiet zu
beenden schon lange ist es Verhältnis
zwischen Serbien und dem Kosovo
angespannt die ehemalige serbische
Provinz hatte sich 2008 für unabhängig
erklärt Serbien erkennt das aber nicht
an
obwohl Afghanistan jede helfende Hand
gebrauchen kann haben die dort
Regierenden islamistischen Taliban
Frauen verboten für nicht
Regierungsorganisationen zu arbeiten was
das für Afghanen und Hilfsorganisationen
bedeutet dazu gab es heute einen
internationalen Austausch über die
erschwerte Arbeit in Afghanistan
berichtet Thomas gonzia
sie sorgen für Kranke retten Leben sie
sorgen für Essen und Trinken helfen bei
der Verteilung sie sorgen für Bildung
für wissen
sie sind Frauen in NGOs hassina Rafe
arbeitete für die
Menschenrechtsorganisation Action eight
sie zeigt bewusst ihr Gesicht
ich bin in die Familien gegangen habe
Frauen aufgeklärt etwa in
Gesundheitsfragen und nur Frauen dürfen
Frauen helfen es ist sehr konservativ
nun das Verbot Unterstützung für Frauen
und Mädchen fällt also weitgehend aus in
einem Land in dem laut UN zwei Drittel
der weiblichen Bevölkerung dringend
humanitäre Hilfe brauchen Hilfe kaum
möglich ohne Helferinnen sie
verschwinden aus dem öffentlichen Leben
aus Schulen aus Unis nun aus NGOs
deren Sprecher bekräftigten deshalb
heute per Videokonferenz ihr Engagement
Ruhe teils auch die medizinische
Versorgung das Ärztinnen doch noch
zugelassen sind sei nicht garantiert
momentan sind alle Programme ausgesetzt
das heißt von mobilen Kliniken über
Dorfschulen über die Verteilung von
Kleidungsstücken für den Winter
bargeldverteilung die Leute zum Heizen
brauchen damit sie Heizmaterial kaufen
können all das jetzt in der kalten
Jahreszeit lebensgefährlich aber wir
haben letztendlich keine Wahl ohne
unsere Kolleginnen können wir diese
Arbeit nicht machen es ist dringend von
Nöten dass dieses Verbot aufgehoben wird
hassina wollte weiterhelfen sie wollte
die Zukunft Afghanistans mitgestalten
islamistische Männer haben das verboten
Reisende aus China müssen in immer mehr
Staaten eine negativen corona-test
vorweisen zum Beispiel in den USA in
Indien und Italien die Bundesregierung
sieht aktuell aber noch keinen Anlass
für eine testpflicht in China breitet
sich das Coronavirus seit Ende der
strikten nullcovid-politik rasant aus es
ist der höchste Anstieg an Infektionen
weltweit und Krankenhäuser wie hier in
Peking sind stark überfüllt
zu den vielen Maßnahmen in der
energiepreiskrise zählt bei uns in
Deutschland auch die wohngeldreform das
heißt Haushalte mit wenig Einkommen
dürfen mit mehr Unterstützung rechnen ca
2 Millionen Menschen wären ab Januar
bezugsberechtigt und viele von ihnen
danach sieht es zumindest stark aus
müssen wohl lange auf ihr Wohngeld
warten warum dazu jetzt Dominik Müller
Rosell
am laufen seit vier Monaten im September
hat Hans-günter Müller seinen Antrag auf
Wohngeld gestellt gehört von der Behörde
hat er seitdem nichts dabei gibt sich
die Stadt Krefeld alle Mühe hinterher zu
kommen hat extra eine neue
Beratungsstelle eingerichtet doch da
immer mehr Menschen Wohngeldanträge
stellen ist eher nicht der einzige der
wartet und hofft
wie möglich bearbeitet werden kann muss
man halt die Zähne zusammenbeißen und
abwarten doch das Personal ist knapp und
hinzu kommt das ab Januar deutlich mehr
Haushalte in Deutschland einen
Wohngeldantrag Stellen werden als
bislang und es tut Chaos denn in vielen
Bundesländern wird die notwendige
Software erst im April fertig sein
ärgerlich auch für die Städte die vielen
Antragstellern dann sagen müssen dass es
erstmal nichts gibt wenn gleich man in
Krefeld unbürokratisch helfen möchte wir
werden für die Personen wo wir
befürchten dass eine Wohnungslosigkeit
möglich ist oder die Gefahr besteht den
werden wir sehr zügig das Geld
überweisen eine pauschale überweisen die
wir dann natürlich danach wieder spitze
abrechnen aber dann stellen wir auf
jeden Fall sicher dass die Menschen die
es wirklich brauchen das Geld auch
bekommen das fordern auch die
Sozialverbände von allen Kommunen und
darüber hinaus einen Zahlungsaufschub
für Menschen denen Hilfen zu spät
bewilligt werden
das ist ein Moratorium gibt für Strom
und gassperren und auch natürlich für
Mietrückstände wenn Menschen wegen der
hohen Belastung und jetzt Ihre Zahlung
nicht mehr tätigen können mehr Wohngeld
für mehr Menschen soll es geben nun muss
das Geld ankommen bei denen die es
brauchen
sie wissen in zwei Tagen ist Silvester
und nach zwei Jahren böllerpause sind
Raketen und Co in diesem Jahr wieder
erlaubt heute hat der Verkauf von
Feuerwerk begonnen und die Branche die
rechnet mit einem Umsatz von 120
Millionen Euro das wäre in etwa so viel
wie vor Corona aber die Kritik an der
Silvester Tradition die wächst neben
Umweltbedenken wegen Feinstaub und Müll
warnen Ärzteverbände vor dem hohen
Unfallrisiko und das bei ohnehin schon
stark belasteten Kliniken Sabine com
berichtet
bereits um Mitternacht lange Schlangen
vor den Toren des feuerwerkherstellers
in Bremerhaven um 6 Uhr dann der
Verkaufsstart
diese pyrofans möchten beim werkverkauf
die ersten sein nach der corona-pause
lassen sie sich das Spektakel am Himmel
wieder ordentlich was kosten
zwei Jahre dass wir nicht richtig feiern
konnten und dadurch muss man natürlich
wie dieses Jahr ein bisschen anders
werden ne ja
es soll anders werden bunter
gleichzeitig bleibt das ungute Gefühl
dass all das nicht zu diesem Krisen und
Kriegs ja passt Kritik am Böllern auch
angesichts tausender Menschen die sich
beim Zünden von Böllern und Raketen
verletzen und verarztet werden müssen
viele Notaufnahmen und Krankenhäuser
sind wegen der starken infektwelle schon
jetzt am Limit ich spreche mich gegen
das jährliche Böllern aus weil es
immerhin 8000 verletzte jeder Silvester
nach Statistik gibt die dann versorgt
werden müssen in der Zeit in der wir
ohnehin erhebliche Belastungen haben und
ich spreche mir auch deshalb gegen aus
weil es in Zeiten in denen in Europa
Krieg geführt wird kein gutes Zeichen
ist wenn wir Kracher und raketenzünden
so schön die Pyro Effekte sind so
unterschiedlich die Meinungen dazu auch
auf der Straße früher als Kind war nicht
toll aber wenn man da so ein bisschen
drüber nachdenkt also eigentlich ist es
nicht nicht gut für die für uns für
unsere Welt der ganze Lärm mit für die
Tiere und so weiter ist jetzt auch nicht
das das schönste Jahresende Erlebnis für
Vögel und so weiter finde das einläuten
in das neue Jahr mit lautstarken
Feuerwerk einfach toll ich mag es mir
gerne angucken egal ob Böllern oder
nicht allen gemeinsam bleibt die
Hoffnung auf ein gutes friedliches neues
Jahr
auch die silvesterkonzerte hatten in der
Pandemie ja vielerorts Pause oder fanden
nur unter Auflagen statt in der
Semperoper in Dresden wird in diesem
Jahr Beethovens Neunte gespielt es geht
sicher auch fröhliche aber der Klassiker
ist bewusst für diese Zeit gewählt steht
das Werk doch als Symbol für Frieden und
für Verständigung heute Abend das erste
von drei Konzerten und Anja schalewa bei
der Generalprobe dabei
Silvesterkonzert in der Dresdner
Semperoper mit der 9 sinfonie von
Beethoven setzt die Sächsische
Staatskapelle und der Leitung von
Christian Thielemann einen spektakulären
Höhepunkt diese Hymne für Freiheit und
Gleichheit ist in Zeiten von Krieg und
Krisen mehr als eine Tradition zum
Jahreswechsel
wir haben ja sonst immer Operetten oder
Filmmusik oder eben sehr leichtes
vermeintlich leichtes gespielt und wir
haben uns dieses Mal dazu entschieden
die 9 sinfonie von Beethoven zu nehmen
eben gerade auch wegen der allgemeinen
Lage
ist es ja einer hier eins jener Stücke
was eigentlich immer passt
also weil das so universell die die
Menschen anspricht beethoven war bereits
taub als er die Sinfonie schrieb und
revolutionäres wagte neben dem Orchester
führen zu Schillers oder an die Freude
erstmals Gesangsstimmen zu einem
grandiosen Finale
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das Dresdner Publikum ist begeistert
nein das sind von hier ist immer
wirklich der Kracher steigert sich
langsam am Ende Bums super schön die
Kapelle der Chor das war super
beeindruckend ich hatte Gänsehaut
Beethovens Neunte ein Symbol für Frieden
und Verständigung nicht nur an diesem
Abend in Dresden
[Musik]
das Konzert in der Semperoper können Sie
heute Abend hier im ZDF sehen direkt
nach dem heute journal um viertel nach
10 so jetzt zum Sport Rudi da war ja
wieder ordentlich was los auf mit dem
Pisten und auf den Schanzen genau auf
der Schanze fangen wir auch an Harvard
hat das Auftaktspringen der 71
internationalen Vierschanzentournee in
Oberstdorf gewonnen vor 25.000 Fans an
der Schattenbergschanze war der Norweger
erneut eine Klasse für sich Karl Geiger
und Andreas Willinger belegten die
beachtlichen Ränge 4 und 6
der Wind bestimmt den zweiten Durchgang
in Oberstdorf geduldet gefragt die Fans
überbrücken mit Fangesängen das Objekt
der Begierde dieser Tournee der Goldene
Adler strahlt genau wie der Sieger des
heutigen Tages Halver etnagrane Rüth ein
Norweger der derzeit in einer anderen
Liga springt der Anlauf verkürzt gerade
Nerven stark wie schon im ersten
Durchgang auch im zweiten Bestweite 139
Meter
13,4 Punkte sein Vorsprung auf den
zweitplatzierten Polen Petry Schüler der
seinen Landsmann David Kubatzki auf
Frankreich verdrängt und die deutschen
beweisen wieder einmal die Tournee
beflügelt sie bester Deutscher Karl
Geiger Alster Teamkollege Andreas
Wellinger überzeugt mit einem guten
sechsten Platz
und Katharina Althaus hat beim zweiten
Springen des erstmals ausgetragenen
silvesterturniersplatz 2 belegt den
Tagessieg im österreichischen Villach
sicherte sich erneut Eva pinkelnig aus
Österreich
mit 34 so gut wie noch nie so zumindest
die aktuelle Leistungen von der
führenden in diesem Turnier von der
Normalschanze waren es zwei blitzsaubere
Sprünge die zum erneuten siegreichen
zweimal 94 einhalb Meter für Eva
pinkelnig 5,6 Punkte am Ende vor ihrer
schärfsten Verfolgerin und die kommt aus
Deutschland
Katharina Althaus die Olympia aus
Oberstdorf springt im zweiten Durchgang
auf 92 einhalb Meter einen halben Meter
weiter als im ersten Durchgang heißt
Rang 2 die starken Leistungen deutscher
Springerinnen komplettieren Celina
Freitag auf Rang 4 und eine Rupprecht
auf Frank 5
na bitte kurz vor seinem geplanten Start
im Super-G in Bormio in Italien hat
Olympiasieger Matthias Meyer aus
Österreich spontan seine Karriere
beendet eine ungewöhnliche und
überraschende Entscheidung Sieger auf
der Stelvio der Schweizer Marco oder
Matz bester DSV-Starter einer insgesamt
enttäuschten deutschen Mannschaft Josef
Ferstl auf Rang 16
das war es aus dem Schnee vielen Dank
Rudi zum Schluss sagen wir noch leise
Servus zu einer Kurznachricht die über
150 Jahre lang per Postbote kam nämlich
das Telegramm zu Silvester stellt die
Deutsche Post diesen Service jetzt
mangels Nachfrage ein Telegramme waren
früher die fast einzige Möglichkeit
dringende Nachrichten an Menschen zu
schicken die kein Telefon besaßen
fröhliches oder auch Trauriges was
schnell übermittelt werden musste die
günstigste Variante die kostete zuletzt
zwölf Euro 57 habe ich
so von Westen zieht morgen Regen auf es
bleibt stürmisch und mild mehr dazu
gleich von Katja horneffer das heute
journal mit Marietta Slomka um 21 Uhr 45
das war es von uns morgen an dieser
Stelle Barbara Hellweg für Sie noch
einen schönen Donnerstagabend
[Musik]
guten Abend in den vergangenen 24
Stunden ist erst die warm und dann die
Kaltfront dieses Tiefs über uns
hinweggezogen und kaum ist das Tief
abgezogen kommt schon das nächste
formatlantik hinterher heute Nacht hängt
hier noch die kalt von südlich der Donau
und so fällt dort auch noch Regen und
auch in Norddeutschland gibt es noch
einige Regenschauer der Winter hat etwas
nachgelassen auf dem Brocken im Harz gab
es ja heute eine orkanmöhe mit mehr als
133 km pro Stunde an der Nordseeküste
weht der Wind aus West südwestlichen
Richtung heute Nacht sinken die
Temperaturen auf 7 Grad am Oberrhein und
bis auf 1 Grad zum Beispiel im
Berchtesgadener Land und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen an der Ostsee und
in östlichen Mittelgebirgen um 7 Grad 14
Grad werden es dagegen am Rhein und der
Tag geht erstmal freundlich los sondern
Wolken wechseln sich miteinander ab aber
ab den Mittagsstunden verdichten sich
die Wolken im Westen immer mehr und es
beginnt kräftig zu regnen der Wind
bestimmt wieder zu und kommt aus
südlichen Richtungen und dann kommt der
Silvestertag und der wird exorbitant
mild am Oberrhein gibt es vielleicht
sogar 20 Grad und auch die Nacht auf
neuer wird sehr mild 10 bis 15 Grad sind
es dann der Neujahrstag ist dann ähnlich
mild und in Norddeutschland ist es dann
nicht mehr ganz so stürmisch wie noch an
Silvester bis bald